die afg hat bei den wahlen im osten gute
ergebnisse erzielt in sachsen hat 27,5
prozent erreicht ihr ergebnis sogar
verdreifacht und in brandenburg 23,5
prozent das ist fast das doppelte wie
das letzte mal
und auch in thüringen wo demnächst
gewählt wird könnte sie über 20 prozent
kommen
was bedeutet das eigentlich für die afg
selbst denn die ard ist im osten etwas
radikaler als im westen
da gibt es einen sogenannten flügel der
wird geführt von jörn böcker der ist ja
sehr bekannt als jemand der reden hält
die oft für aufregung sorgen der andere
ist andreas kalbitz das ist der afg chef
in brandenburg ja so ein bisschen im
hintergrund aber geht weiß der
strippenzieher der afd
und die frage ist jetzt nach diesen
erfolgen werden also diese leute und
diese kräfte vom flügel jetzt
tonangebend in der ard für die gesamte
partei
und was wird sich entscheiden am
bundesparteitag der afd der ist anfang
dezember und dann werden wahrscheinlich
die ost politiker der afg sagen wir
wollen mehr einfluss haben als bisher
und die frage ist ob zb jemand wie birke
dann antritt um bundesvorsitzender der
afg zu werden
ich bin überzeugt das wird er nicht
machen warum nicht weil er einfach
verbrannt ist medial wie man sagt es
jemand der zu sehr polarisiert zu sehr
zu viele gegner hat auch in der afd
und er hat ja im aussagen gemacht die
für sehr viel aufregung gesorgt haben
[Musik]
der andere der antreten könnte mehrere
eben andreas kalbitz der in brandenburg
die ard führt aber auch da glaube ich
dass er nicht antreten wird dann kalbitz
hat eine ganze reihe von
rechtsextremistischen verbindungen er
war in vielen rechtsextremistischen
verein oder hat dort zumindest leute
gekannt oder war irgendwie dabei ergibt
dass immer alles nur zu wenn man ihm
nachweisen kann
ich habe mich von all diesen dingen oft
über äußert wieder vorgehalten wurden
dazu stehe ich auch aber er hat einen
bestimmten ruf auch der auch der afd
schaden würde wenn er bundesvorsitzender
werden würde
deswegen werden die beiden so glaube ich
im dezember nicht antreten
es gibt allerdings noch andere politiker
der ard im osten die das machen könnten
etwa timocom halla das ist ja ja der aus
sachsen kommt der hat man den bundestag
das bundestagsmandat von michael
kretschmer dem sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten hat das dem
abgenommen in görlitz und erst ein
handwerksmeister und stimmt hat
sympathie für den flügel aber man weiß
nicht so genau ob er dazu gehört oder
nicht das wäre eine möglichkeit
heute wird die fdp geführt von jungen
leuten und alexander gauland alexander
gerade das schon 78 jahre alt und er
sagt jetzt reicht's eigentlich langsam
bin alt genug ich muss das nicht mehr
machen wird ja auch noch die fraktionen
im bundestag aber er sagt ich halte es
mir offen ob ich vielleicht doch
karriere
denn vor zwei jahren war so dass er dann
plötzlich doch obwohl er nicht wollte
kandidiert hat weil nämlich einem
radikale politikerin frau doris seinen
zu wittgenstein um ein haar
parteivorsitzender geworden wäre
er hat nur eine einzige stimme gefehlt
und heute ist diese frau sein zu
wittgenstein aus der afg ausgeschlossen
worden weil sie den holocaust also die
verfolgung und vernichtung von millionen
juden durch die nationalsozialisten
geleugnet hat deshalb musste ich weg das
ganze zeigt wie unberechenbar in der afg
alles ist und es ist auch gar nicht so
sicher dass dieser große wahlerfolg den
sie hier zum osten hat sich wirklich
langfristig gut für die afg auswirkten
im westen wo es mehr gemässigte wähler
und zum teil auch politik aller art die
gibt sind viele erschrocken über diesen
erfolg der afg im osten und könnten sich
auch abgeschreckt fühlen
deswegen kann erfolg der afd im osten
vielleicht sogar langfristig ein
nachteil für sie werden